[Musique]
voici la première photo et kader m'a
demandé de vous demander s'il y avait
quelqu'un qu'il savait ce que c'était
pas la personne mais l'arbre est ce
qu'il vous rappelle quelque chose il
parle à quelqu'un
l'art du ténéré on va mettre la deuxième
vous avez été au musée pour la plupart
je pense que la forme vous la
reconnaissez celui-ci l'art du ténéré le
président le précédent c'est l'arbre
perdu qui s'appelle aussi que les
autochtones ont appelé la syrie à bienne
en hommage de cette personne et ses deux
armes sont parmi les plus isolées du
monde particulièrement le premier
l'arbre perdu le premier arbre le plus
proche est à peu près 200 km de cet
arbre tout autour c'est que du désert
que de l'aridité pas d'eau rien le néant
enfin le désert
je vais demander la troisième photo qui
pourrait dire de quelle communauté cette
dame où elle vit
c'est le cas war c'est une femme debout
[Applaudissements]
indice qui ces femmes chaque année ces
femmes chaque année après la saison des
pluies
elle récolte des dattes dans les oasis
du kawar quai entre femmes et après
elles font une excursion qui dure
plusieurs mois où elle traverse tous les
petits oasis du canard qui égale
l'extrême est du niger au levant au fin
fond du désert près du tchad et de la
libye et pendant toute cette durée elle
traverse
voilà vous voyez c'est des zones assez
désertique doazit son oasis pour vendre
leurs produits et puis faire du troc
aussi m'a demandé de parler de la
résilience pour tout vous dire je ne
sais pas quand vous racontez dessus
jusqu'à aujourd'hui je pense qu'on est
tous culturellement ou naturellement
résilient pour ce qui est des arbres
c'est plus de l'adaptation
parce qu'ils sont dans un élément c'est
comment dire routiniers on va dire entre
guillemets pour ces personnes-là ces
populations qui vivent dans le désert
qu'ils soient tous boutoir et les peuls
boad ab sont confrontés à la résilience
oui ils ont des vies très dure très peu
d'eau les aliments c'est pas toujours
facile d'en trouver
et ils ont réussi à construire leur vie
dans ces dapd dans cette adaptation à la
difficulté de l'environnement il dit
personnellement moi je ne peux pas dire
j'ai été confronté à ce genre de vie
jusqu'à l'âge de 15 ans j'ai une vie
dorée
j'avais un papa qui avait gagné beaucoup
d'argent avec son entreprise déjà
traversé le pays pour lui demander de
l'aide
donc je peux pas dire que j'ai eu je
suis tombé sur des grandes difficultés
dans cette période là par contre j'ai
grandi à agadez
j'allais beaucoup à la campagne on nous
dit bruce ici je jouais avec mes amis
dans la rue donc j'étais au contact de
gens qui ont des vies très difficile je
pense vous aussi tous mais ma première
expérience où j'ai eu peut-être
confronté à quelque chose d'un peu
difficile est arrivé vers l'âge de 15
ans en fait moi ma mère est française
je n'ai découvert plus tard que j'étais
un peu français j'ai grandi à d'abord
agadez puis à niamey j'ai jamais imaginé
dans ma vie même je pensais pas aux
études supérieures encore que j'allais
vivre en france et c'était au moment de
la conférence nationale au niger et
comme partout dans beaucoup de pays
d'afrique
il ya eu des révoltes ou d où des
manifestations qui ont été plus ou moins
entre guillemets violente et il ya eu
une rébellion au niger à ce moment là et
mon père un peu plus tard voyant que les
gens ne voulaient pas aller vers le
dialogue forcément il a il s'est senti
dans le devoir de rejoindre les rebelles
pour différentes raisons
surtout pour tenir un peu tout le monde
je pense
et donc il ne l'a été obligés de nous
envoyer en france donc moins le constat
que j'ai eu avec l'arrêt des singles
l'approchent gerica résidence à ce
moment là c'est plus émotionnel c'est de
me retrouver dans un autre pays
un espèce de réfugiés dans des bonnes
conditions
mais c'était surtout voilà pour vous
dire émotionnelle après plus tard dans
la vie bien sûr on est tous confrontés à
des épreuves je pense que tout le monde
ici à des expériences à partager par
rapport à ça voilà c'est ce que tout le
monde vit vous parlez de la résilience
je pense que ça c'est quelque chose qui
est culturel quelques et naturel lettres
s'adapte obligatoirement
la vie il y à des millions d'années la
planète à aurait subi des météorites qui
serait tombée sur la planète les
dinosaures seraient aurait disparu à
cette période là mais la vie a continué
la nature a continué à vivre
peut-être que c'est nous l'espèce
humaine qui aujourd'hui lui faisons le
plus de mal mais dans l'ensemble les
êtres vivants
la planète est résiliente elle et les
êtres s'adapte
surtout moi ce qui m'intéressait
aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter une
autre personne quelqu'un du niger dans
les plus jeunes
est ce que quelqu'un que c'est qui est
cette personne
vraiment beaucoup à main c'est grandes
personnalités de l'époque contemporaine
on est un jeune pays on va demander un
autre voilà pour boamah qui a dit le
plus grand bien que l'afrique peut
apporter à notre commune humanité dans
langlois et son grand retard celui là
même qui manquent à l'occident
industriels pour devenir humain plus
humain aujourd'hui moi je sais plus
vraiment dans la case de la jeunesse
malheureusement je commence à avoir des
rides un peu de vendre mais je
m'approche de la sagesse beaucoup
beaucoup de jeunes gens parlent de
résilience de changement etc etc
nos populations sont résidents ti nos
concitoyens sont résilients mais parfois
dans nos actions dans nos actes dans nos
réflexions
nous voulons ce changement nous sommes
une minorité
nous sommes une petite minorité nous
sommes en 2010 9 mai à beaucoup de gens
au niger dans le sahel dans beaucoup de
pays qui sont pas la même époque il ya
des gens comme je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure il ya des gens qui vivent
pratiquement comme au néolithique et
nous les changements qu'on veut il faut
qu'on les mesure il faut qu'on les
mesure parce que parfois on attend leur
résilience dans nos volontés dans nos
souhaits dans nos ambitions dans nos
aspirations et il faut penser à ce que
les choses se fasse en douceur pour ces
gens là parce que c'est parfois violent
pour eux
pourquoi si moi j'ai un concert est
donné aujourd'hui à la jeunesse tout
d'abord surtout beaucoup de jeunes comme
moi qu'ils sont enfants de nantis qui
auront le plus de chances demain de
décider d'inspirer de motiver les
changements de motiver des politiques
démotivés des décisions d'être sûr de
prendre les bonnes décisions et pour
ceux d'aller découvrir plus le pays
parce que pour la plupart nous avons
fait les meilleures écoles nous avons
des moyens nous serons meilleurs
position demain pour décider inspiré de
l'avenir nos pays et si on ne connaît
pas les réalités de nos pays si on ne va
pas les découvertes de nos pays
en restant toujours dans les capitales
dans les centres urbains
on risque justement encore d'atteindre
la résilience de ces populations en
prenant des décisions parfois qui sont
contraires à leur mode de vie qui sont
contraires à leur mode de pensée qui
sont contraires à leur culture parce que
nous n'avons pas forcément tout à fait
la même que quand on est en ville quand
on est en campagne
normalement c'est surtout ce conseil que
je voulais donner aujourd'hui surtout à
l'endroit de la jeunesse du niger merci